alright hey everyone its micro order
folks and welcome to my presentation or
Flo's 2.0 trading in sync with the
market now my goal for you today is to
show you the new developments in order
flow analysis show you how to let the
market tell you when to buy or sell how
to trade in the present based on what's
happening now and how to easily see
high-percentage order flow trade setups
you know as traders that's what we want
we want high percentage trade setups you
want the trades that are going to put
the money in our trading account maybe
stick around to the end I have a special
gift for you it's my 150 page book
trading order flow you know I can get
the actual hardcover copy what you're
going to do is you're going to get the
link to download it online and you can
download it to your phone or your Pete
to your tablet it's in PDF form so you
could read it pretty much on the go so
briefly Who am I for those of you that
aren't familiar with me my name is
Michael Balto's I'm the owner and
founder and trader at order flows comm
which I started three or four years ago
2015 prior to that I spent eight years
at JP Morgan as vice president of
Futures Trading and it's not like some
job where I just sat in a corner office
all day long and looked at numbers noise
i sat in front of the train terminal for
eight years there and iterated every day
did the same thing at Commerce Bank as a
license Jurek's trader spent three years
there at Cargill same as well
daily trader there I ended up being a
trading desk manager for them in
Singapore and prior to that I spent two
years at EDF man on the global macro
trading desk and you know we literally
traded everything there that you can
imagine you know EDF man is big English
trading company you know they've been
around since the 1700s got their start
trading sugar and prior to that I
started on the CMA floor with Dean
Witter as a runner and I left the floor
when Globex and project day and night
Mex
access started taking off in the mid 90s
and I worked upstairs on there off the
floor trading desk I spent three years
there so that just gives you a
background of who I am and where I come
from and you know what I talk about is
based on my own experience trading on
the institutional side and we know when
I talk about the importance of law
him I know because you know I used to
pull those I don't wanna say call them
tricks or anything like that but you
know I know how volume influences the
market because I've had to trade big
size and I've had to finesse it into the
market without telegraphing it to the
market you know how to get the
advantageous price and get a good fill
you know and and all that
all the training that I did you know it
shows up in the order flow it shows up
in the volume there's no way to hide it
once it's been executed you know you can
hide your order through various types of
now you use algos before you had to do
it manually but you know once your
trades it shows up the trade shows up in
the volume it's disseminated out through
the world and time and sales and if
you're not looking at that information
you're really leaving an important part
of trading out of the equation so in
2013 I left JP Morgan to spend more time
with my family I'd recently gotten
married at our first child and I really
just wanted to spend time with my family
you know and that that's the what
trading can do for you is if you're
successful it's going to give you some
freedom in your life to do what you want
to do and shortly thereafter about a
year later I started writing my book
trading order flow and I was still
trading and I realized that you know
with computers they could do the heavy
lifting for you they can do some of the
analysis for you so I was training with
the order flow using a volume footprint
chart from another software vendor and
it was just a basic volume footprint
charters paying over $1,000 for it a
year and all I did just told me the
volume that that's it but you know I
know that software can do much more and
for me you know I was looking at certain
things in the order flow that I felt
could be programmed you know areas of
price rejection price support absorption
and other little market nuances so I
created the order flow trader software
and it runs on ninjatrader 7 and
ninjatrader
8 however with the new ninja trader 8
changes so to speak you know on the way
they handle data it really blows mt7
away and recently we came out with a new
version of order flows trader
specifically for Mt
eight we didn't we still have the MT
seven version but the NT eight version
has more features to it so you know if
you're going to use a ninja trader go
directly to ninja trader eight don't
stop at seven I mean and that's that's
the future for ninja trader eight at
this point there's still support a ninja
trader seven but other development goes
into ninja trader eight anyway and what
I'm presenting in this presentation is
what I've developed for myself and built
my trading career on and I hope you can
find things that you can use and adapt
into your own trading you know I'm not
saying that you have to follow what I
say just because I say it no you have to
evaluate everything you come across
whether it's from me or from other
traders and decide if it's going to help
you if not reject it you know we all
read trading books right everyone's read
at least a dozen trading books and you
don't take everything that person says
is gospel no you take what resonates
with you and you apply it to your
trading plan so let me be clear you have
to make trading decisions that's what
life is about that's what trading is
about you know in life it's all about
making the right decisions in trading
it's also all about making the right
decisions order flow by itself it's not
a red light green light trading system
but when you understand order flow the
markets will become very clear for you
decisions will be a lot easier and you
know your life will be I think a lot
less stressful now before I begin let me
go over a brief disclaimer you know this
presentation is for educational and
informational purposes only it should
not be considered a solicitation to buy
or sell a futures contract or making any
other type of investment decision a
futures trading contains substantial
risk and is not for every investor an
investor could potentially lose all or
more than the initial investment risk
capital is money that could be lost
without jeopardizing one's financial
security or lifestyle only risk capital
should be used for trading and only
those with sufficient risk capital
should consider trading past reports is
not necessarily indicative of future
results now you know before every
presentation I always go through the
disclaimer because you know I want
people to understand there is risk
involved in training it's not like you
just open an account and you
automatically make money no you can lose
all the money you put in the account you
can lose even more than that
but you know if you follow a good plan a
good trading plan and you have a good
set of tools to trade with your chances
of success are much higher now I've
worked with a lot of successful traders
previously in my institutional side and
I've worked with a lot of unsuccessful
traders on the retail side and basically
what it comes down to is successful
traders make the best use of available
information and they process that
information and in in an intelligent way
what I mean by that is having a firm
grasp of the elements of market analysis
as well as a sense of which factors are
important in which situations and you
know perfect example I see people all
the time using you know off-the-shelf
indicators such as you know RSI or MACD
and they just swear by it as possible
they don't take it in context with
what's happening in the market and I
think that's the big problem you know
just because you know an indicator says
well we're overbought doesn't mean we
can't go
moreover BOTS or more overbought and
more overbought as the markets trending
you know every time you try to get short
when the market is overbought but you're
in a trending market you're gonna get
your head handed to you okay and you
know take things in context and try and
think about what's happening in the
market and and use it alright and you
know apply it to you know just common
sense
analysis sometimes you know sometimes I
get the feeling that some traders just
throw out common sense off the window
when they sit down in front of a trading
terminal okay so the first thing I talk
about is the new developments in order
flow analysis now this is specific to
the order flows trader software and like
I said when I develop the order closed
trader software there were four
indicators that we had programmed in
there and recently with our launch of
the updated version for ninja trader 8
we've added another four indicators in
there and it was actually three plus
we've enhanced one so it's a total of
seven indicators you get in there and
that's what you know being you know
being good at something is you gotta
keep innovating you got to keep adding
things to it like a perfect example was
Michael Jordan you know the basketball
player when he started out you know he
was just known for a slam dunks right
that's it you know that you wouldn't
slam dunk competition even though he's a
good overall basketball player but then
you know as he's progressing in the NBA
with the Chicago Bulls
and I realized his body couldn't keep
taking you know taking the fouls so he
had to develop more you know he started
using a jump shot more than he only
started using a three-point shot more so
you know it's about expanding your game
and trading is the same way you know if
you just trade with one indicator you
know how does your indicator work does
it work best in trending markets or does
it work best in sideways markets because
if it's good in trending markets when
the markets in a sideways mode you're
not gonna make any money you just going
to lose money and same as if you have a
trend trading system if you you know if
you're trading a trend trading system in
a sideways market you're gonna you're
gonna end up taking a lot of losses
until the trend comes you know some
people are fine with that but you know
oftentimes the psychology of traders is
you know they starts having a few losses
they give up and they stop trading the
way they're supposed to trade so you
know that's why we keep developing tools
to add into the order post trader
software so that you can take advantage
of trending markets of sideways markets
so you know it's like having a grocery
store right you don't sell just one item
and grocery store you sell many
different items and I'll say it's about
diversification but you have to have
some a method for trading when a market
is trading one way and a method for
trading it when it's trading the other
way you know you can't just keep trading
one system in all market conditions it's
just not going to be viable so one of
the new developments for order flows
trader 2.0 is we have probably we call
prominent PLC's market sweeps multiple
imbalances and we've enhanced the
existing trap traders indicator and then
so these are all in addition to the
single prints the existing trap traders
the order flows divergence and the
ratios you know the ratios are an
indicator that now you know many other
software are adding it into their native
software and you know they don't want to
give me credit for it but you know
people have been around with me you know
people have been trading order flow for
a long time know that I'm the one that
developed it and you know sent me
messages saying hey you know so-and-so
software added it into there
you know they're calling it the order
flow algorithm nonsense like that and it
is really nothing earth-shattering about
it but you know what you know I just
wish you know it your credit were
credited to do that's all you know I
mean order flow is available to
everybody and you know that's why I do
presentations like this that's why I
post videos on YouTube that's why I
offer my book is because you know a lot
of people don't know what to look at
they don't know what they're looking at
you know it wasn't explained to them
properly I mean you know you could have
a software talks about all these things
shows all these things but if you don't
know how to use it it's gonna be useless
I mean what's the point of having ratios
if you don't know what ratios to look
for what they mean so I mean you know
it's one thing to have it on your
software but it's another thing to know
how to use it so first one I'll talk
about is prominent pointing controls and
you know point control in the order flow
is the point in the bar with the most
volume
now what prominent what the orchestrator
2.0 does is it highlights the prominent
opponent controls the point of controls
that are important and these often acts
often act as support resistance
especially in in range-bound markets but
also in trending markets they could
signal the end of a trend alright they
could be a signal beginning of a trend
it could also signal the end of a trend
and they could also signal I'm gonna
show you some examples of you know how
they react in a range bond market and I
finally worked great in markets that I
have low speculative activity and high
commercial activity you know markets
that are really dominated by supply and
resistance great example would be bonds
you know where's minis although they do
work nicely in minis you know you mean
these is market that's really driven
with a lot of speculative activity
retail traders so to speak and you can
see here this is a minis how the markets
just react
you know prominent point control here
rallies up to a primary point control
here and it sells off alright if you
have my template it will color it blue
for a bi or magenta for a cell you know
for support area for a resistance area
now there are some people that do like
to just they use the parameter point
controls as the basis of their trading
plan and
some I dare say trade them you know by
themselves naked you know without any
confirmation but I think you know when
you add them into your existing method
of trading it's going to help you find
turning points in the market now market
sweeps market sweeps our areas where big
traders sweep the market you know they
buy or sell through several price levels
in one trade and what that means is you
know say the market is too bit at three
okay and you're a crude trader and you
just did a deal in the physical market
and you know futures are gonna react to
it so what you do is you pay up to seven
right markets to binet three you bid you
sweep the market up to seven you
literally buy every offer all the way up
to seven you turn it seven bids
sometimes and this happens a lot in
certain markets crude is a great example
you know markets where there's a lot of
physical activity going on physical I
mean you know there's you know like in
the cash market that's being traded and
then you know someone will have the edge
of position in the futures and actually
the old nymex access system it was the
old electronic system that was out in
the 90s by the exchange actually had a
feature in there where you could sweep
the market that's that's where you know
you know traders have been around for a
while we'll talk about sweep in the
market you know the old Karate Kid
analogy sweep the leg Johnny uses you
know say that on the trading desk he'll
sweep the leg but it happens and it can
show up in the order flow and again if
you don't know what to look for
you're not gonna see it and you know one
of the features that I've added into the
order post trader 2.0 is to highlight
these market sweeps so you're gonna see
you know a darker red arrow or a for a
sell or rather a green arrow for a buy
dark green arrow and oftentimes they
come out of nowhere
you know market is going sideways
someone sweeps the market thinks the
markets gonna sell off they sweep it and
look at what happens this is Nasdaq you
know we're trading from the 71-72 area
you know you get a sign of a sweep and
we sell off nicely down into the 70 150
areas you know
the point moved there you know not every
example is gonna be as great as that but
you know they are they are quite quite
nice when you see them you know it was a
do it cells off to an area of a
prominent pony control and then it
starts rattling multiple imbalances now
you know if you're familiar with order
flow you understand the concept of
stacked imbalances stacked imbalances
are imbalances that are neatly stacked
on top of each other one on top the
other but a multiple imbalance is when
there are three or more order flow
imbalances in a bar they don't have to
be stacked on top of each other you
could have one and then a regular price
level with no imbalance then another two
imbalances that would be considered a
multiple imbalance and I treat them
actually the same as I do a stacked
imbalance and you can see here how the
market is just sort of drifting lower
drifting lower boom it hits too low the
rest of buying comes in you've got
multiple imbalances here you have four
one two three four and then the market
makes it starts making its move up so
what's happening is you know the market
is sort of you know it's coming in for
its low you know like an airplane coming
in for its landing you know an airplane
doesn't land at a 45-degree angle
now oftentimes it just sort of comes in
and starts forming its base and then it
takes off again and that's what's
happening here
you know we're coming in at these low
prices traders recognize that these are
very good these are low prices this is a
good buying opportunity they start
getting aggressive and they start buying
it you have the aggressive buying coming
in it's showing up in imbalances and you
see how the market starts rallying again
so you know those are the three main
thing I'm not talking about the trap
enhanced trap traders because you know
honestly it's it's a bit more complex
that I have time for but um it's going
to be very useful for you let me just
believe it to you at that so secondly I
want to talk about is letting the market
tell you when to buy or sell again it's
not I'm not trying to predict the market
now trying to predict highs or lows I'm
letting the market tell me that now halo
is being made or hey a high is being
made or you know a trend is underway get
in it's not trying to predict you know
where the market is going it's reacting
to what the market is doing and getting
on board for the ride now remember every
trader has
the same information that's how you use
it that makes the difference so rather
than just try and guess the future
direction of the market just listen to
what the market is telling you what the
direction is going to be again you know
traders oftentimes like to over
complicate things and I said Sarah you
know they sort of try to read the market
like tea leaves and say oh you know I
think you are based on this this this I
think you know down you know a week from
now what to be trading here why bother
with that you know you just try and get
on board with you know if the river is
flowing in one direction right you throw
a piece of bread into it it's gonna
float in that direction you are that
piece of bread you get on you know you
jump in you write it until it's done
it's like surfing right you ride the
wave so prominent point controls perfect
example okay this is this one I didn't
have the settings properly when I pulled
up this chart this is the default
setting it's not the settings on my
template but there's actually a by here
so you can see we're coming down into
this low we start forming our base base
base boom you got a prominent point of
control indicating support of buying and
then we rally up here you got signs of a
sweep you got multiple imbalances so if
you're not convinced with just this
prominent point of control here you have
a bullish ratio then here you got the
multiple imbalances you got the market
sweep then you can see how the market is
rallies from 63 all the way up to 68
okay here we're in a trend the trend is
forming okay we're starting to rally
multiple imbalances this bar this part
of this bar you have stacked imbalance
but you also got multiple imbalances and
here you have sweep this is a dark green
arrow another sweep here so you know a
buyers coming in buyers being aggressive
pulls back hey you know what I still
think is a good buy someone sweeps the
market up you get more multiple
imbalances market pulls back more does
it pull back notice how it pulls back
each level to these ponent controls each
previous point of control previous point
control previous point of control
someone sweeps the market again and
right just keeps going up you know I
mean you should have been convinced by
this bar not not this third bar but even
if you are at this third bar you're
still catching a nice move here again
it's about letting the mark
tell you what's happening and reacting
to it you know you see a multiple
imbalances you start breaking out of a
sideways zone right we're basically
trading sideways in here boom multiple
imbalances boom northern multiple
imbalances and a sweep you know at this
point it's all systems go this is
actually the Delta surge going on right
here I could tell them that Delta yet
increasing Delta here it's also a
bullish sign but I'm not even talking
about Delta in this presentation now we
just talked about these new tools but if
you you know you when you start putting
all the pieces together really you know
the least thing these setups become
second nature and you can really take
advantage of it okay here you have the
divergence primary point of control
multiple imbalances now if you're
familiar with my order flows analysis
you know that what a divergence is
that's this red arrow here and then if
you have a blue number in the ratio
that's that's a good sign
that's what you're looking for you're
looking for blue numbers means that the
ratio is a certain number above a
certain number or below a certain number
and I'm not really concerned with what
the ratio is I'm more concerned with if
it meets the threshold so in this case
it does meet the threshold that's why
it's blue as opposed to black black is
just indicating your normal order flow
so again if you have this no order flow
software and you know the programmer
just wanted to add the ratios into it
every ratio you have is that it's a
comic sense to you that's why we color
the important ones a certain color so
here you have racial divergence and this
is a bread and butter trade you know
there's people that just trade this by
itself every day and have very good
results but when you start adding in
other aspects of order flow here this
bar here you have another divergence
it's the same high you've got a primary
point of control okay so the first bar
on your high you have divergence and a
ratio second time you hit that high
double top
you got ratio I show you had divergence
and a prominent point in control say not
convinced yet
then here as you start coming off you
got the aggressive sellers coming in you
got out multiple imbalances that's this
purple box around the bar and then you
sell off and you saw off where you saw
off to a new low that's why I have
another divergence here
and the other important thing is you
don't notice you're at your high and
look at this Delta it's all negative
that's also very important but ratio and
divergence go time ratio sorry
divergence and primer potent control
it's also go time you've seen multiple
imbalances off the high it's also go
time
each one of these bars is telling you
hey don't get long gets short you know
price action traders will say well we
hit the high we came off we started
rolling back up to the high get long no
no you gotta get short here based on the
order flow not position yourself to get
long and it's the same thing almost here
you got divergence divergence but this
second bar you have divergence with the
prominent point of control and you have
the ratio afterwards tell people that
have been around you've been using the
order flows trader 2.0 just the regular
order flows trader this is a trade setup
I've been talking about for years
literally since I started operating my
software is the divergence on the bar
that the new high or new low in the bar
afterward with the ratio I still
consider that a valid set up and so you
got your ratio so you got your ratio you
got your divergence and you got your
ratio but in this part you have your
divergence prime opponent control and
the ratio so you got three things going
there also the deltas are strongly
negative you're up here at your highs
you got mostly negative Delta again you
know put it two pieces together and you
start to see a clearer picture okay so
you have all the signs here you're at
your high you got negative Delta so you
know you know you got net aggressive
sellers
you got your divergence you got your
prominent point of control indicating
there's resistance up here then you got
your ratio here this is a bearish ratio
in the sense of price rejection you have
single print also so what's happening is
mark is selling off its tries to come up
a little bit but prices these higher
prices are being rejected and we
continue to sell off okay so here you
got a bunch of Parana point of control
you got real ratio multiple imbalances
you got your sweeps come down into a low
you got your primary point control you
got a bullish ratio okay
primary point of control bullish ratios
0.68 three three
come in here form a double bottom
another prominent port of control on
this bar here that's on the low
you also got multiple imbalances all
right one two three four they're not
stacked neatly on top of each other like
in the next bar but in the next bar you
also got multiple imbalances but you
also got a sign of a sweep happening in
here come our kit sweep and boom or you
do it rally up all right we come off a
little bit continue rallying you know
this one is a sign of some sweep trap
traders going on right here as well but
you know you could at least caught part
of that move and it's not like oh you'd
buy it here and sell it up here no you'd
you know bought it in here and sold it
somewhere in here hopefully ideally you
should have been buying down here you
know based on this first bar here so you
don't need to try and predict the future
just trade on the information that's in
front of you you know don't try to
predict eyes your lows you don't have to
but if the market is telling you hey
there's a low being formed here okay you
know try and get in on that let move
back up right or if you have a high
being formed okay great
you know after you know the highest set
that's when you get short you don't sit
here they don't want to try and pick
this high no hey the markets telling you
hey there's a high forming in here okay
if you know there's a high forming
what's the trade to take is to get short
you're not gonna be buying at the high
thinking we're gonna make a new high you
know if you think a high is being made
you position yourself to make take the
move lower so you know trading in the
present based on what's happening now
you know don't necessarily trade you
know on on the past and when I say the
past I mean you know stuff from like an
hour ago three hours ago you know people
use moving averages or you've incumbent
you know some sort of indicator based on
a moving average you know sometimes
they're taking information that happened
50 bars ago 100 bars ago and really what
how is that useful now thinking this
sort of goes back to what I just talked
about trading in the present you know
people are always trying to predict
what's happening in the future
concentrate what's going on right now
it's like an invading
you know there's some girls that will go
out on a first date and they're already
planning their hair wedding and you know
how many kids are gonna have and all
that stuff
then the guy breaks up with her because
she's not concentrating on what's
happening now she's concentrating on the
future I'm trying to predict the future
don't do that you know concentrate look
at what's happening now base your
training decisions on what's happening
now based on what the market is telling
you and you just remember you know no to
trade setups are going to be exactly the
same you know there's numbers involved
in terms of volume and it's not going to
be exactly the same when all ratios are
not going to be exactly the same but in
general they look very similar that's
why some of these charts look very
similar is because that's what happens
you know you it's sort of uh I don't say
it's a pattern but you know what you're
looking at is you know ratios you look
at point controls you look at Delta
numbers and you want it to be around a
certain threshold and once you reach
shows those levels then you know that
those are the trades you're going to
take it's not going to exactly be you
know every Delta that's 1,000 you know
no because you know not every bar Delta
is going to end up on 1,000 you can see
every bars got a different Delta you
know and you know not every low is going
to have a prominent point of control but
you know you can see here right this is
one's tom market is selling off you got
a nice prominent point of control here
at the low your rally up to your
parameter point of control here now this
is a move from one sixty ninety five all
the way to one sixty one twenty five and
look at this time from 138 to 151 so you
know about twenty minutes for that move
and it's just a straight up move you
know there are some traders that just
use prominent point of control and trade
that you know I I prefer to sort of add
a few more things into my analysis than
just using prominent controls but there
are people that use them and again
you're on Range you know this is a
trendy market you can see how it caught
this trend up here on a range bound
market you see how it's picking every
high and low you know you sell off to a
primary point control your rally to a
compliment control you sell off to a
prominent point control you rally back
up to an area
we got the multiple imbalances now trap
traders same thing some traders some
there are some traders out use this as
the basis of their trading plan and you
can see here
swing low to a swing high to a swing low
now some people say well you got trap
traders right there you don't didn't
work out well where are we going to be
taking the trade you taking it up here
not down here
again take things in context in the
market right where do you want to be
getting short you want to be getting
short after and move up not after move
down to get short you want to be getting
long after a move after move down you're
looking for an area to buy not area to
sell but even if you took it so you got
short off this you know I just went
sideways yeah you would have taken a
loss but you had a nice winter a nice
winter then another nice winter here I
mean even if you got short here you're
not gonna hold it because you had a buy
signal here this is a problem with some
traders make is they get short off this
bar which they shouldn't have in the
first place
it should be short from up here but they
get short here and then they get a buy
signal but then they just sort of sit
here well you know I'm not taking the
buy because I'm still short I'm gonna
let it work out no you have to you get
us if you're trading any type of signal
and you get a short signal then you get
followed up with a buy signal you got to
get out of the position and think about
getting long you're not gonna stay here
and stay short and hope it works out I
think if you're a fundamental trader
okay and you you you're along the market
because there's a drought okay then all
sudden starts raining okay and you're
like well you know we've been in a
drought for a week you know for a month
rather and it's just a little bit of
rain I'm just gonna stay short you know
if it's if if it starts raining you know
the whole reason for being the drought
is there now you're not gonna stay in
that position are you know because the
prices are going to start going down
because there's more rain comes you know
the crops crops are saved so to speak
and you know the whole reason for being
long being you know your reason for the
trade being the drought is over alright
you don't sit there and say well
going to dry up in room being around
conditions again no everything's changed
the fundamentals have changed and it's
like that with you know trading with
which order flow you know you have your
reason for the trade but then another
reason comes in now you have a fresh
reason you know if you're trading you
know some moving averages or whatever or
things based on the past you know that
that look you know have a some period so
you're going back 20 bars you're not
taking into account what's happening now
you're basing it on what's happened you
know off the charts already you know
from the long time ago so here's the
prominent opponent controls racial
multiple imbalances we're forming our
low here I know we have a divergence
earlier but I'm not talking about that
one and you got your ratio your point
one zero six eight
you have your prominent point of control
as well next bar you have your multiple
imbalances so here you know it's just
letting the market tell you hey you know
what we're gonna start to rally you off
this low you might want to think about
getting along and then what do you do
your rally up all the way up to another
prominent opponent control where the
market starts to selling off from you
know then you got your your trap traders
up here and you got a bearish ratio and
you start going down but again you know
you'll be getting long from here sixty
five all the way up to you know the
ninety area before you get a bearish
sign that the markets gonna start
selling off you know catch those rides
catch those moves
now here's soybeans ok seller surges
soybeans I'll show you is Dow I showed
you crude oil emini x' euro currency so
in different markets you know it's the
same concepts you're looking at in the
different market so you got trap traders
trap traders trap traders also got
bearish ratios this is a three in a row
this is a setup I like just with the
ratios and you had a prominent opponent
control indicating resistance up here so
what's going to happen what he expects
going to happen we're going to sell off
you know if your price action trader I
hold out our high we've come off we're
starting moving back up let's get long
no you can't based on the order flow
because it's telling you got resistance
here even in these these are bearish
ratios indicating resistance you got
trapped traders what's happening is all
these price action traders are buying it
thinking the markets going back up
instead they're stuck there long and
wrong market comes off to try to move it
back up market comes off they try to
move it back up but instead they're just
fighting it you know they're they're
paddling up river you know against the
flow of the of the tide then it comes
down here and where's it stop it stops
in an area where you have a prominent
point of control and it just goes
sideways from there you're just cause
you're a prominent component control
doesn't mean it's going to immediately
bounce and rally most more often than
not it does but it can also go sideways
like this you know what's going to
happen after a move is one is going to
reverse to it's going to go sideways and
three it's going to go sideways and then
sell off some more and it's your point
your decision and her shot your job
rather as a trader to notice that then
notice that hey this move down is over
you've hit this prominent point of
control you've hit an area of support
okay
now it's time to get out and reassess
what's happening in the market again
trap traders this is bonds and he's how
the market rallies up market starts
selling off what happens people start
coming in here they can hey you know
what we're just getting a little bit of
a pullback let's rally just like it did
here you know hit our swing high market
came down but then buyers came back in
buyers are coming back in they're trying
to buy it but they're these people are
realizing that there's some big sellers
up in here and then you can see it gets
slapped no three Lots trade 465 206
that's like nothing in the bonds you
know you see generally most price levels
got you know but thought over a thousand
in it and this is already during the
days as 8:00 in the morning and at that
time you should be getting at least
around at least a thousand at each price
level yeah three you know so you know
the market just got slapped right here
and one could slap like that it doesn't
just immediately come right back it
often has more more to that move and you
can see how it sells off down here you
got a racial divergence here in this
case just starts going sideways how can
you tell it's going sideways or there's
two ways you got these pointed controls
lining up at the same price levels and
then you got bearish ratio bullish ratio
that's also a sign when you started
alternating ratios like this bullish
bear
foolish it's also a sign about market
going sideways you know that's what
order flow can help you with is
determine if a market is going sideways
so there's two things got ratio ratio
ratio bullish bearish bullish he also
got pointing controls lining up at the
same price level so you know the market
sort of going sideways there okay so the
last thing I'll talk about is how to
easily see high percentage order flow
trade setups now again you know as a
trader that's what you want you want the
high percentage trades you know
oftentimes traders try to trade the
trading method trade their trading
system they don't take all the trades
you know as a trader you have to take
all the trades that come your way don't
sit here and try say well you know I
don't think this one sets up properly
I'm not gonna take it no you have to
take the trades when they're there
period because what's going to happen is
you're gonna take the trades that don't
work and you're gonna miss the trades
that do work so now don't try and get
fancy you know if you have a method of
trading you trade it now don't sit there
and try to nitpick your trades you know
before you take them if it says buy you
buy says sell you sell and again you
know how do you get a high percentage
trades is by putting the pieces of water
flow together and what you do when you
start doing that you're really taking
advantage of what's happening right in
front of you again it's gonna is is you
know there's a debate is order flow a
leading indicator everyone knows that
you know things like Mac the RSI moving
averages are lagging indicators but I
wouldn't call necessarily order flow a
leading indicator I call it a present
indicator
let's based on what's happening right
now so you're coming down into a little
prominent point of control right here on
the low you got a sweep going on you got
multiple imbalances record screaming at
you hey buy me buy me I'm a great price
yeah you'll be buying it here in the
next bar at 45 even you know we do your
rally all the way up into the 70s 80s
even divergence and ratio this is my
bread and butter trade from the original
order foolish trader and I still look at
it today you know I mean I don't need to
program anything that give me an arrow
up or down I got eyes I can
see oh I got a racial divergences go
time these are the trades I love to take
and you can see how it sells off nicely
118 even all the way down into the 117
85 area and again primary point of
control here and the divergence in this
bar I even have the ratio afterwards so
you're starting adding a little bit more
into the mix and then the the end
product tastes better again ratio and
divergence here even in an x-bar prana
apana control multiple imbalances again
it's the market is telling you hey get
short here don't think about getting
long and again if you're missing say you
miss the ratio never just should be
keyed in on the the primary point of
control if you're not then you got the
multiple imbalances you know it's giving
you so many signs up in here then the
Delta as well and there's still some you
know meat left on this move from the
2748 area down into the 43 that's five
points in the snps you know some people
are happy to get five ticks this is five
full points and it happens within 30
minutes yeah I see a lot of people say
well yeah you know I'm done trading this
method in the SPS and I made three three
ticks or we try to have three ticks or
three full points you know here I'm
giving you methods to get points out of
the market rather than ticks here trap
traders divergence racial product but to
control all appearing in this bar you
know of course you got the positive
Delta as well but that shows up in the
divergence so here you got your
divergence you've got your trap traders
that's the green arrow it's they're both
superimposed on top of each other
you got the bullish ratio and you got
the problem opponent control here the
only thing I should use this bar also
you have a multiple imbalance I'd have
it turned off on this on this chart or I
think I have it set to a different
number but there is sorry it's not a
sorry I was confusing this this ratio as
part of the the footprint but it's an
you have two imbalances okay I'd like to
have three but there's two showing up in
here I mean that would really be like
everything in the kitchen sink involved
if you had a multiple imbalance going on
but you don't you don't but it's fine
you've got
other things going on you got your
divergence you've got your ratio you got
your prominent point of control you got
your trapped Raiders you know you're at
your low and it's just screaming at you
get long get long if you're getting
along somewhere in here at 42 Porsche
rally rallies all the way up to 47 and
more divergence in prominent point of
control boom you hit it you sell-off
that's what you're looking for you're
looking for these things you know it's
sort of like you're a hunter you know
you're lying in wait for the the animal
to come you know before you start doing
your thing as a hunter and you know that
that's what trading is about no training
is boring you gotta just sit and wait
you gotta wait for the market to show
you something reveal itself then you act
on it you know it's not about always
being in a position no you know you wait
for the high percentage opportunities to
come along and you trade it you know
it's just like playing poker I mean I'm
no poker expert but you don't sit there
go all-in on every hand no you sit there
in your weight you doesn't set up you
know it's not a nice hand your fold nice
and you fold you know nice and you fold
then when you get in a good hand that's
when you press it you know that's when
you you go and you try to maximize the
return it's like that we're trading you
know nothing is happening here that's
worth getting in a position on but then
you get your divergence you get your
primary point control hey you know what
things are starting to set up for me I
go oh I got negative Delta I've got a
delta surge forming in here yeah those
are the things that you know once they
start coming together that's when you
get into the trade that's when you take
the trade you know it's not while trying
to ride every move up and down no you
wait for the optimal time to get in you
know it's like an surfers don't write
every single wave you know they try to
wait for the best wave that they get the
most out of and you can see it rally it
cells off from the primary point of
control to to a primary point of control
down here on the buy side so from the
sell to a Buy so you know the move is
over they start rallying back up you
have another primary point of control
right there
divergents prime opponent controls same
thing I just finished explaining now
you're waiting for the market to show
you something and showing it to you
right here with the divergence and the
prominent point of control and your
rally back up and that's what you want
that's what you're looking for as a
trader now finding those moves and
exploiting them taking them for all
they're worth so hopefully by now you
can see how powerful order flow analysis
is is you know how I don't say how I've
made it you know there's always out
there but how I've programmed a lot of
these my type of analysis the analysis
I've always been doing into the software
basically what I wanted to do is take
what I the thought process I go through
in my trading and put it into the
software so you can see the exact same
thing
don't try to over complicate trading
that's what a lot of people do they over
complicate things not just in trading
but in life and they make end up making
judgments without sound analysis you
know I was saying I you said tell people
particularly my ex-girlfriends don't
over complicate things and people spend
80% of the time worrying about things
are never going to happen and it's the
same thing with trading sometimes you
know people try to over complicate
things by thinking about stuff that's
not gonna happen or things that's
useless to think about and I was like oh
hi my wife and I will get into arguments
about something that hasn't happened and
I'm like why are we even arguing about
this or you know things that happened a
long time ago that she still wants to
litigate right now you know don't don't
you know we've already that's been
settled you'll move on and think about
what's happening right now so hopefully
if you found this webinar useful you're
gonna like my order flow straighter 2.0
software package now remember all right
90 to 95 percent of traders basically
lose their account in the first year why
do you think that is well because they
keep trading the same way that the
previous 90 percent of loosening traders
do you know if it's broken it's not
going to work again you know when you
throw the water out of a cup it's not
going to go back into the cup and you
know if you're trading with methods that
are proven to not be successful don't
think you're going to
make it successful son you know you
might have some short-term success but
over the long term no you're not you
know and I Got News for you all this
stuff has been you know all these
indicators in the sense of you know RSI
moving averages that's been data mined
to that by not only by retail traders
but by you know hedge funds
everyone just trying to find an edge in
the market and you know if there is this
very short term and it doesn't last very
long so again you'll stop doing what all
the other losing traders are doing you
know stop flushing your money down the
toilet buying some fancy indicator
rather learn how to trade the market
understand what's happening take
advantage of it and profit from it you
know if once you understand how to read
the market you know trading really
becomes simple everyone likes to have a
red light green light system says buy
here sell there but again you know you
got to take everything in context of the
market now that's not to say that there
aren't any trading systems that are
worth you know worth money you know I do
know some and they're very expensive you
know I know I know some that you know
have very high percentage winning days
out of the trading month but you know
get access to it costs an arm and a leg
and most traders don't want to pay that
you know it's not cheap and I'd rather
you know teach people how to read the
market and make the decisions themselves
I mean ultimately who's going to be
responsible for your training success is
you no one else so you know what I have
is the oracles trader 2.0 that runs on
ninjatrader eight is the volume
footprint chart with all the indicators
you saw in this presentation and you
also get my chart template so you know
what to spend like these trying to
figure out how to set up your chart to
look like mine you know going back to
they don't only give you my chart
template they even give you a little
video shows you how to install my chart
template onto your ninja trader just
drag and drop basically and you me you
know your trucks will be looking just
like mine now that that's really what
you want
and normally I sell this for eight
hundred ninety nine dollars but you know
having the order flow software is one
thing next thing is you gotta know how
to use it you know what to look for so
you know I don't just give you software
so here you'll figure out order
by yourself you know no I provide you a
lot of further eggs the education on how
to trade with the order flow so give you
access to the Oracles training course
which I also normally sell for 297 I
sell it every day on my website for 297
is 20 lessons is 15 hours of video
instructions you're gonna get that for
free when you buy the software package
today and to sweeten the deal because I
know that you're interested in order
flow I have my order flow inner circle
video series now this is 56 videos on
advanced order flow trick I hate comp
tricks but tips and analysis and this is
different than the regular order flow
inner circle the inner circle there's
additional indicators that come with it
this one is just the videos where I
really talk more in depth about
different order flow trade setups you
know even if you just get one or two
things from this it video series you
know it's going to be worth it to you
but I would give you that for free and I
said it's 56 videos it's not like a two
or three-minute video these are videos
that go anywhere between 30 minutes to
an hour and really cover a lot of ground
on order for or this is stuff that's
never been shared other people just my
inner circle group and you're gonna get
access to that for free so you know when
you start adding it together you know
that software is $8.99 the trading
course is 297 the video series is 497
that's already 1693 1693 but you know
because of investor inspiration inviting
me back to their presentation I'll give
you also access to the trader kickstart
training which is it's a 12 course or
not it's a 12 piece video course on the
mental side of trading the mindset of a
trader you know what why traders succeed
why other traders fail you know how to
put together a trading plan how to get
your you know beat the stress that's
involved in trading how to get into a
daily routine a lot of that information
that you know traders take for granted
you know people think well I you know I
can just start trading and be successful
no you also have to have the right
mindset and that's what the trader
kickstart does is it helps put you in
that mindset and you get access to that
for free so you
and all that up 899 297 490 79 that's
almost $2,000 it's 1990 but I kind of
pay that you're gonna pay just 749 so
one-time payment that's it you're not
paying any more payments no monthly fees
or any other payments in the future I
mean of course you do need to pay for
NinjaTrader but actually the ninja this
my software will run on the free version
of ninja trader so if you have another
trading platform that you use boom you
install ninja trader on another PC we
run the software on it make your trading
decisions trade on your other platform
you can do that ninja trader you can buy
a license if you want to trade through
an approved broker but yeah there's a
lot of people that use the free version
and run my software on it of course you
also have to pay your data fees but you
know if you have a brokerage account you
know any pain like $5 for CME $5 for
CBOT so go to order closed comm slash
off to HTML and I'll take you to the
payment page and so you know other
people are saying oh don't just take
what I'm saying no other people there's
some people that don't like me and post
negative things but there are people
that order closed trader has changed
their trading you know you see here
Sheila writes your order flows trader
software is remarkably helpful I can see
clearly now what's happening in the
market like for example who's in control
on the market on a very specific time
and who's getting weaker as well so
again you know and this is this is a
person that you know wanted to help
supplement their income by trading you
know they're not sitting there thinking
they're going to become the next Paul
Tudor Jones now they just want to make
you know ego you know grind away at the
market every day and get some money in
their pocket extra money in their pocket
and you know I'm always pleased to help
traders like that you know people that
want to learn so go to order flows calm
slash off to to HTML and it takes it to
this page scroll down to the bottom and
there's some videos on there there's
actually a 30-minute video on there
40-minute video actually where I walk
through several days in different
markets and explain to you show you you
would buy here you would sell here now
this is what's happening in the order
flow you should watch that video it's on
there it's not this first one it's the
second video on there
but what you do is when you get to this
page at order flows calm slash off to
HTML you scroll down takes into this
page now you see a timer here okay and
when this timer hits zero which is
Sunday night you're not gonna get access
to the trader kickstart anymore you'll
just get the regular bonuses so click
here by now I want this and it takes it
at PayPal PayPal processes your payment
I don't get your credit card information
I don't want your credit card
information yeah if you've ever bought
anything from eBay chances are you're
familiar with PayPal you know that's
their big that's the payment processor
most everybody uses on on eBay so it's
everybody knows what PayPal is or should
know and if you don't have a credit card
you could also pay still you know down
here pay with debit or credit card and
just go to order closed comm slash off
to two on HTML and you're gonna join
order flows today because you see the
power of order flow training and
analysis and how it can change your
trading you wanna understand what's
happening in the market you want to find
low restraint opportunites but more
importantly and this is the big thing is
you want freedom and fulfillment in your
life like for me I get fulfillment from
teaching other traders I already have
the freedom training has given me that
freedom in life to do what I want to do
if I want to go on vacation with my
family I can go on vacation with my
family it's always been that way
training has been very rewarding to me
as a as a person so go to order flows
calm /off to HTML now in the beginning
this presentation I said you can get a
copy of my book trading order flow go to
this link order flows calm slash book
HTML and you can download yeah enter
your email okay and you're gonna be put
on a list so that you can be notified of
other presentations I do in the future
or any specials I got running so don't
be surprised oh my gosh you know you
sent me spam well that's the trade off
unfortunately but um you know at least
you get a nice nice information out of
it so go to order closed comm slash book
that HTML they get information on how to
download my book for free so right now
go to order flows calm slash off to to
to HTML
get on board you know don't miss this
opportunity to trade change your
training you know think about where you
are right now on your training
think about where you were six months
ago are you any better off you know it's
not a big investment I'm asking it
making a lot of people tell me I should
be so I should be adding a zero on to
the price of this but you know I don't
you know and I don't want to because if
this is sort of my way for giving back
to people yeah I charge a nominal fee
but you know there's I got software
developers to pay and and all that stuff
going on that it's it's I can't give it
away for free I'm not a programmer I got
to pay people to do the programming for
me so you know think about where you are
now think about where you want to be how
you're gonna get there okay think about
those choices you have to make or you
know sometimes they get people saying to
me oh yeah you know I bought your
software two months ago but I haven't
installed it on my computer yet I'm
thinking why you know why not you know I
mean it's like do you want to make that
change in your life if you do get the
software if you don't want if you just
want to keep on going slogging through
life you know trying to figure out the
markets by yourself okay go ahead but if
you really want to change your life
I'll see you know change your life but
you don't want to improve your trading
then get the software get the training
go through the training start looking at
charts start understanding what's
happening in the market so thanks
everyone and again you'll go to order
closed comm slash off to to dot html'
and I hope to see you on the inside and
we take advantage of the bonus I mean
it's it's a great bonus the opportunity
so thanks everyone and have a great day
bye-bye